mes bien chers abonnés pardonnez moi car
j'ai péché oui j'ai pêché sur cette
vidéo qui s'appelle des voeux une cage
de stop mensonge spécial 100e vidéo
j'ai reçu un message du dit stop
mensonge l'invitant à faire une vidéo
avec lui pour discuter de ce débat mme
cage j'ai répondu oui alors je sais donc
pas si ça se dira il ya 40 de réponse
voilà j'ai répondu oui et on l'a jamais
fait voilà donc je suis je suis je suis
coupable mea culpa et j'ai bien mérité
ma pénitence bon la raison pour laquelle
ça s'est jamais fait c'est parce que
deux semaines jour empêche je crois que
c'était deux semaines après ce message
en gros la personne quitter un stop aux
mensonges laurent friman a fait une
interview pour la tronche en la tronche
en live sur la chaîne de la tronche en
biais et je voyais pas trop quoi
rajouter à ce que là parce que cette
vidéo apportait est aussi en regardant
cette vidéo de la tronche en live j'ai
réalisé que laurent friman et moi même
ne vivions pas du tout sur le même plan
de l'existence c'est à dire que je mon
esprit scientifique vit dans un monde
matérialiste où les conséquences ont des
causes vérifiables et réciproquement
laurent friman je crois pas on y vit
dans un monde où il ya des choses
complètement invisible et impalpable qui
ne qui existe quand même
voilà donc moi je un axiome à moi c'est
je pars du principe que si ça se voit
pas que ça peut pas se toucher que ça
peut pas se tester globalement c'est que
ça doit pas exister
voilà il clairement il vit pas dans le
même plan de l'existence que moi de ce
point de vue là donc voilà c'est un peu
là c'est un peu le plan ucly bien qu'ils
essaient d'expliquer à la sphère que de
droite ça peut pas se croiser deux
droites parallèles ça peut pas se
croiser bon cette voie là c'est
impossible
on ne peut pas se comprendre voilà je le
prend pas de haut
juste qu'on ne peut pas se comprendre
voilà j'ai réalisé en regardant cette
vidéo de la tronche en date que de toute
façon vous pouvez discuter pendant des
heures concours jamais on arriverait à
se comprendre pourquoi donc pas la peine
on est pas on n'a pas du tout le même
concept de réalité
a la base je puis dire donc voilà et
aujourd'hui je vais donc expliquer ma
faute
en lisant un article évidemment de stock
mensonge la magnifique article sur la
glande pinéale ou troisième oeil
voilà déjà troisième ace à 100
l'ésotérique ça sent fort l'ésotérique
alors c'est un article qui m'a été
gentiment recommandé par mais les
abonnés voilà alors pour pas balancé le
nom
masta gonzo merci d'avoir recommandé cet
article que vous pouvez voir ici donc
c'est parce qu'il ya quelques il ya
quelques semaines de cela j'ai publié
une petite photo sur facebook
accompagnées de cette explication ici ou
en gros je parlais du fait que nos
ancêtres les reptiles malien avait un
trou au sommet du crâne que vous pouvez
voir ici qui était pour un troisième
oeil qu'on appelle l'oeil pinéale donc
l'oeil pinéale c'est un organe
photorécepteurs très similaire aux yeux
normaux au final vous voyez qu'il ya une
cornée un cristal à une rétine comme un
homme normal
comment on sait ça parce que les
reptiles moderne en ont un et final vous
voyez un varan ici par exemple le varan
de komodo un troisième oeil le
les iguanes ont un troisième oeil et le
spin o dont le fameux tout atar à de
nouvelle zélande je crois d'ailleurs
fait une très belle vidéo d'un stylo
dont ces notes on her eyes est
évidemment comme pour toute chose c'est
en anglais qu'on trouve les bons
contenus n'est ce pas il me semble que
c'est celle là où on voit très bien le
sténo dont le troisième oeil dessus du
lot de belles explications
en couple vous 3e et du slogan donc
voilà ce 3 tab est aussi un troisième le
bronze 3e 1 il ya été perdus au cours de
l'évolution il y à peu près de 140 de
145 millions d'années
et là où c'est intéressant c'est que
sachant le rôle que joue le troisième
oeil dans la thermorégulation c'est à
dire dans la régulation de la
température du corps eh bien il n'est
pas impossible que cette perte du
troisième match soit lié à l'évolution
même de la deûle endothermique c'est à
dire du sang chaud au final bon elle est
un peu longue cette vidéo quand est ce
qu'on arrive au projet mais là on y est
donc voilà c'est le sommet du crâne du
screen dont ils vont nous localiser le
troisième oeil en trois dimensions c'est
un super de reportages moustoir donc
voici le troisième oeil dans toute sa
splendeur la cornée on a vu la rétine le
cristallin le nerf donc le fameux le
nerf pinéale qui conduit le tout à la
glande pinéale donc vous voyez que c'est
vraiment comme un oeil qui a son petit
nez raluy et ou quoi donc c'est pas
complètement du fantasme cette histoire
de 3e rien c'est pas du s'est pas
complètement du tout en fait du fantasme
c'est juste que mais est-ce que l'être
humain à la troisième elle non la
réponse est non
par contre on a une glande pinéale
effectivement si ce petit point rouge
que vous voyez au centre du cerveau ici
on a une glande pinéale qui est
finalement un reliquat de ceux de ce
glorieux troisième oeil de nos ancêtres
les victimes à malien alors qu'une chose
à savoir importantes à propos du
troisième homme je vois yam'tcha ici qui
à son troisième et vous voyez au milieu
du front alors petite interruption j'ai
eu du mal à trouver ma page mais
le troisième âge chez les reptiles
malien il est situé dans un foramen qui
s'appelle le foramen pariétal et ce même
format même pariétal comme son nom
l'indiqué il est situé entre les eaux
pariétaux or sur votre front par
définition c'est palaiseau pariétaux
c'est les autres on pose des eaux en
rouge ici sur le second il crâne sur
votre front or le foramen pariétal s'il
était ou que ce soit ils seraient entre
vos os pariétaux et du coup ça il ya une
petite mutation qui fait réapparaître le
foramen le foramen pariétal une mutation
d'un gène qui s'appelle msx2 et quand
cette mutation a lieu doit vous voyez il
ya des fora même qu'ils apparaissent sur
le pariétal vous en voyez ici vous
envoyer la voilà donc vous pouvez voir
des défauts ramène du pariétaux ici ici
et là place il ya d'intéressant sur
celui là c'est qu'il est en plein milieu
en plus donc s'il devait si un troisième
oeil
il devrait y avoir chez l'humain le
troisième un il serait pas situées sur
le front il serait situé la voilà à
l'arrière du crâne complètement donc
yamcha il n'est pas hyper réaliste de ce
point de vue là et donc c'est tout ça
parce que eh bien le foramen pariétal
est situé sur les pariétaux or le
problème c'est que comme on a un très
gros cerveau en fait les offrons taux
qui sont à l'avant ici sont beaucoup
plus courts que les eaux pariétaux qui
se sont grandement étendue due à
l'extension du cerveau chez l'humain ce
qui donne du coup se fera même pariétal
poussé complètement à l'arrière du crâne
et c'est aussi dû à la position de la
glande pinéale vous voyez que la glande
pinéale elle est située à l'arrière du
cerveau voilà elle est dans ce coin là
elle n'est pas située dans ce coin-là
donc pour kia pour qu'il y ait un oeil
finale ici il faudrait que la grande
finale se situer là avec le nerf qui va
penser de direction or là sachant que la
glande pinéale et la relique de l'oeil
de ce qui reste de l'organe sur lequel
il y avait un oeil devrais-je dire eh
ben elle est située à l'arrière du
cerveau et c'est logique du coup que le
foramen résiduelles associés soit situé
à l'arrière du cerveau
donc voilà ça c'était c'était la raison
pour laquelle aujourd'hui je vais
m'attaquer à la glande pinéale donc
encore une fois merci masta gondo
on va stagner homme a aussi suggéré un
article de et nichane on a déjà fait et
dit chez anne alors je vais pas faire
les deux
on a déjà tapé sur sur est nichée année
et sur son site de les informations donc
c'est parti pour deux envie de dire le
papa de la désinformation stop mensonge
la glande pinéale ou troisième oeil
alors des bonnes cage de pénitence 1 me
le rappellent les deux grands principes
fondateurs
il faut que l'article est plus de succès
que nous mêmes bon en l'occurrence cet
article à 48,9 eu donc je pense qu'il a
plus de succès que 90% de mes vidéos il
n'y a pas de souci de toute façon la
réputation de spock mensonge n'est plus
à faire de ce point de vue là donc le
donc
règle numéro 1 et respecter un seynois
david et c'est lui goliath et la règle
numéro 2 qui est une règle que j'ai pas
toujours respectée mais que je vais
essayer de respecter à partir de
maintenant c'est de c'est de ne pas
avoir lu l'article avant bon déjà parce
que quand je vois les l'introduction
généralement je me taille les nerfs
envie zoé et je ferme la fenêtre donc
finalement je les lis pas c'est
seulement en y revenant après que je me
dis tiens ça ferait ce serait bien quand
même d'en parler mais bon conseil il
faut que je ne vise donc du coup la
seconde règle tacite c'est que en gros
j'ai pas lu l'article avant et du coup
je fais tout en totale improvisation ce
qui m'évite en plus d'avoir à lire
plusieurs fois l'article
sachant qu'à chaque fois ça fait
extrêmement mal donc commençons la
glande pinéale situé au milieu du
cerveau humain est considéré comme étant
le troisième oeil car elle dispose d'une
membrane qui capte les images comme
celles au pont de la rétine des yeux la
glande pinéale est remplie d'eau et
c'est la partie la plus magnétique du
corps bon évidemment quand on parle des
hauts terrils on parle toujours de
champs magnétiques évidemment mais on va
pas parler de la partie magnétique la
juste cette partie là voilà déjà c'est
important que c'est bien que j'ai fait
cette présentation parce que justement
de ce qu'est le troisième oeil et de ce
qu'est la grande qui
chez l'homme parce que comme je les dis
la glande pinéale c'est le résidu du
troisième oeil qu'avait nos ancêtres les
directives malien rien à voir il n'y a
plus de ya plus de structures comme
celle reptiles là il n'y a plus il ya
plus cette structure corner cristallin
rétine tout ça c'est relictuelle il ya
elle n'est plus photoréceptrices elle
n'est plus photo réceptive ou
photoréceptrices notre glande pinéale
c'est une glande par définition c'est
juste une glande
elle n'a qu'un rôle sécréteurs elle
sécrète les hormones qui permettent de
contrôler les cycles biologiques
elle n'a plus aucun rôle photorécepteurs
donc déjà confusion majeure entre glande
pinéale est pas idéal donc l'oeil
pinéale qu'on me trouve que chez les
reptiles et la glande pinéale qui est
son petit résidus qu'on trouve chez
l'homme la machine looking glass et le
oriane cubes sont des répliques
technique de cet attribut naturel que
nous avons tous dans le cerveau sont des
engins fantasmé qui doivent certainement
permettre de produire de l'énergie à
volonté comme puis les engins tentation
dans la bible parce qu'un bon article
bullshit ne commence pas à 100 une
citation de la bible luc 34 à bondues ça
c'est fait que nous maintenant de light
of the body is y aille d'abord où on
your eyes single the whole body is also
is full of live one y en a ici vol
et en bonus aux foules of darkness
traduction la lumière du corps l oeil
citons haye est unique citons haye est
unique tout ton corps sera rempli de
lumière mais quand on est y est le mal
ton corps sera dans les ténèbres donc
est-ce que le mal c'est le fait d'avoir
des yeux pers je ne sais pas que veut
dire ce qu'est ce que ça veut dire
je ne comprends pas s'il vous plaît
traduit une autre traduction pour
traduire la traduction s'il vous plaît
est ce que est ce que le fait d'avoir un
oeil un père est ce que les bornes ne
sont plus gentils que l'epa borgne je ne
sais pas où vas-tu avec cette citation
explique je répète si ton oeil est une
iq parce qu'il a écrit en majuscules il
ne parle pas des yeux ici mais de l'oeil
2 l'oeil de celui qui est repris dans la
culture et les croyances bouddhique le 3
le troisième oeil
l'aïe qui connecte le corps et le corps
à notre esprit la glande pinéale quand
une fois un oeil
c'est pas une glande l'oeil n'est pas
une l'ordre
admettons donc l'oeil qui connecte le
corps à notre esprit reprises d'ailleurs
de notre très cher des cartes des cartes
qui avait dit que la glande pinéale
était de l'antenne réceptrice de l'âme
dans notre cerveau pourquoi parce que
c'est situé au milieu du cerveau bon on
n'est pas à l'abri de dire des conneries
même quand on est les cartes un point
est loin d'ailleurs j'attire votre
attention sur le fait que si le
troisième oeil est le réceptacle est une
antenne qui permet de capter l'âme
est-ce que je vous remontre le petit ce
fait nous dans ah non on va juste mettre
voilà faire die pagnol ait un donc pas
tomber sur trop d'ésotérisme pagnol
et puis on va mettre et voilà donc
regarder un petit peu la taille que peut
faire ça c'est un bébé ce fait nos dons
voilà donc regardez la taille du
troisième reich et ce péno donc on est
d'accord que si le troisième oeil est le
réceptacle de l'âme l antenne qui permet
de relier la chair à l'esprit la nôtre
ce fait le don c'est un super guerrier
intergalactique l'alleud ce fait nos
dont il capte à donchery là il a le
réseau 4g la du spirituel
alors le varan de komodo pareil là voilà
son petit peu idéale au sommet de son
crâne
c'est pareil là il a dit il a de la
réception là donc on est bien d'accord
que tanner a encore un bel exemple la de
l'oeil pariétal ça en a l'air d'être un
jour d'iguane et on est d'accord que du
coup si réception il y a de l'âme par
l'oeil idéale sachant que nos ancêtres
avaient comme vous pouvez le voir
quelque chose d'assez président en
matière d'aep idéal on est bien d'accord
qu'on a complètement perdu
ça c'est une fonction qui s'est
atrophiée
c'est une fonction qu'on a plus donc eux
ils étaient en contact spirituel super
plus plus et nous on est on est plus du
tout et voilà on a perdu on est on est
déconnecté tout ça donc
ou est ce qu'il veut en venir là où est
ce que ça veut en venir ce genre
d'article c'est est ce qu'il faut
comprendre qu'il faut se reconnecter ce
qu'il faut c'est con parce que bon si on
suivait juste l'évolution nous a
naturellement amené à perdre notre oeil
donc si on en suisse si on suit ces
logiques de troisième mais ça veut dire
qu'on a naturellement perdu cette
capacité à communiquer avec l'au delà et
avec notre esprit et tout ça pourquoi
vouloir aller contre la nature
pourquoi ne pas après tout pourquoi ne
pas ne pas vivre tel que quelques
l'évolution nous a appris à vivre
c'est-à-dire en observant de ce qu'on a
et pas de ce qu'on n'a pas c'est à dire
un oeil un troisième oeil je veux dire
on pourrait faire un pamphlet dans la
direction opposée quoi c'est ça que je
veux dire c'est que pourquoi faire un
pamphlet pour dire ça mais vous de votre
troisième avec alors qui sert
objectivement plus à rien plutôt que de
faire un pamphlet pour dire notre
troisième oeil il a disparu alors fait
avec mais pas soyons et continuerons ce
qui est drôle c'est de regarder les
différentes traductions de ce passage de
la ville en français en anglais
c'est là qu'on se rend compte à quel
point la bible de nos jours et mal
traduites et impossible à comprendre
je pense que c'est fait exprès pour ma
part je vous laisse juger de la
pertinence de cette phrase les
traductions en français on trouve la
langue du corps c'est l'oeil
si donc pour nay est simple encore est
entier ton corps tout entier sera
lumineuse mais si l'on est malade
ton corps tout entier elle sera ténèbres
oui d'accord donc des fois la lumière
devient la langue unique devient sain et
le bal devient malade oui c'est un peu
le problème de toute façon déjà au de
base on parle d'un texte mythologiques
donc c'est dur a interprété de façon de
façon frontale alors si en plus on se
met à voir à jouer avec les traductions
effectivement on va finir avec du grand
n'importe quoi
par contre quelle que soit la traduction
une chose reste identique on parle de
l'oeil et non pas des yeux
l'oeil est un organe si vous regardez si
vous regardez un livre de médecine en
parlera de l'oeil parce que de toute
façon c'est un organe père et que donc
il n'y a pas d'intérêt vraiment de
décrire les deux yeux comme deux autres
comme une seule entité un soleil suffit
comment être sûr que cet unique est bien
celui que je vous décris la glande
pinéale base pas ça parce que c'est pas
une grande
d'un point de vue physiologique à quoi
ressemble de la glande pinéale la glande
pinéale ressemble comme 2 pas ou
d'ailleurs d'où d'ailleurs elle tire son
étymologie c'est mignon comme une pomme
de pain pourquoi pas sylviane si c'est
bien cela on doit pouvoir trouver une
confirmation quelque part non une
confirmation de quoi que ça ressemble à
une pomme de pain question quelle est la
plus importante statut de lapin au nom
qu'elle est la plus propre
quelle est la plus importante statue de
la place du vatican quel est le symbole
utilisé par le pape pour une pré le
trait d'union entre la terre et le ciel
la chair et le spirituel qu'elle est le
symbole bouquinistes pour illustrer
l'illumination
quel est le symbole élimine intime pu
l'utiliser que retrouve-t-on dans les
symboles francs maçons de quoi parler
les égyptiens quand il parlait de l'oeil
qui doit tout l'oeil d'horus que
retrouve-t-on dans tous les temples
asiatique qu'elles savent on y retrouve
dans retrouve-t-on dans toutes les
tablettes sumériennes la réponse est la
glande pinéale l'aï relié à l'esprit
celui qui voit tout sait tout et qui une
fois activé illuminent le corps tout
entier si je sue place du vatican la
grosse statut du vatican est la plus
grosse aux statuts du vatican est une
pomme de pin le sceptre du pape en son
centre une pomme de pin qui symbolise le
lien entre la paix donc on va faire le
corps et le ciel l'esprit dieu sur mejia
tenant dans sa main une pomme veut pas
et bah on va déjà il va y avoir du
boulot un bon
au delà du fait que ça pourrait tout
aussi bien être juste une pareille dolly
c'est à dire un truc qui ressemble à une
pomme de pain mais qui n'en est pas
forcément une admettons que ce soit une
pomme de pin et admettons que ça que
c'est censé évoquer la glande pinéale
bon je suis pas sûr que les sumériens à
l'époque ait connu l'existence de la
glande pinéale toile honnêtement c'est
ça démontre pas vraiment que l'on
n'avait que la glande pinéale et une
antenne réceptrice de lamu que ce soit
ça veut dire que l a été interprétée
comme telle par par les religieux l'oeil
d'horus comparé au cerveau humain l'oeil
qui voit tout est au centre du cerveau
et j'attire votre attention sur la
remarquable absence de pinéale dans ce
schéma voilà le l'oeil d'horus le dieu
unique censée représenter la glande
pinéale elle est où
alors moi je vous le dis allez là
spoiler elle est là donc c'est pas
l'oeil d'horus la cc le coincer le coin
de l'oeil d'horus les dans le vide en
fait donc donc les égyptiens se sont
emmerdés créé l'oeil d'horus comme une
coupe sagittale du cerveau en oubliant
d'y mettre le truc qui était le plus
important c'est à dire la glande pinéale
en question il faut être complètement
pas ce que je fait qu'interpréter son
dessin je me prononce pas plus la
chambre des 10 des initiations de la
grande pyramide ceux où se trouve-t-elle
comparé au cerveau humain
c'est quoi ça doit être traduit d'un
article en anglais parce que c'est moche
la chambre des initiations de la grande
pyramide où se trouve-t-elle comparé au
cerveau humain en place sur la glande
pinéale dan ans a nié pas la lande
pinéale sur ton chez moi noté noter que
la pause la pause avec un mot se trouve
au milieu de la carotide
à noter que la fosse se trouve au mieux
de la carotide l'endroit où se concentre
la peur qui est l'obstacle principal à
l'élimination alors la carotide surtout
walt sans la peur je ne savais pas que
la peur était une substance
physiologique
donc maintenant on a un schéma de la
grande pyramide par dessus le quai les
superposer le cerveau non l inverse
on a le cerveau et par dessus on a la
grande pyramide et donc on est censé
comprendre que ça se superposent
parfaitement
et oui votre cerveau en coupe c'est
vital est tout à fait triangulaire et
que si on aligne la chambre funéraire
principal avec votre pinéale eh ben on a
une super position absolument parfaite
oui et oui je veux dire même ses 105
convaincre ça c'est censé convaincre qui
que ce soit bon admettons ça le comme
les biberons pourquoi pas mais les
salles le dire tout depuis montre la
parfaite correspondance entre l'oeil
d'horus et la glande pinéale en oubliant
de mettre la glande pinéale nous montre
la parfaite superposition du cerveau
avec le avec la grande pyramide
pourquoi pourquoi pourquoi choisir cette
villa de la pyramide il ya quatre côtés
à une pyramide sans compter sans compter
la ville dessus et dessous alors
pourquoi je veux dire cette bullock un
symbole chiméria donc c'est bien tu as
trouvé un symbole chaud mais rien qui
ressemble à une pomme de pin tant mieux
il y en a d'autres temples en asie doit
pas être plus précis que ça sert à rien
l'arbre de la vie y est un arbre avec
une pomme de pain c'est vrai que c'est
chaud illustration du troisième oeil
comme je le disais le troisième oeil si
il existait chez l'homme il serait pas
là pas du tout donc voilà et l'oeil
franc maçon voilà bon là il
francs-maçons parce qu'on ne peut pas un
bon article l'ésotérique sans une
référence aux francs maçons et aux
illuminati la glande pinéale rendu
beaucoup plus grosse part ce chapelet de
lumière autour je le rappelle la brée
taille de l'allemande pinéale voilà
bouddha qui est à son troisième ris pas
au bon endroit
un dieu sumériens important la
connaissance aux humains dans la forme
d'une pomme de pain
pourquoi pas mais après c'est peut-être
que la pomme de pain est devenu
symbole de sagesse en parallèle la
glande pinéale devant une église en
allemagne pas la glande pinéale
ressemble à une pomme de pin coïncidence
ces sculptures ressemblent à des pommes
de pin ce probablement pas une
coïncidence de là à dire que ces
sculptures ont été faits pour ressembler
à une grande finale plus qu'à une pomme
de part je dirais que c'est un peu une
un peu de l'étirement là il ya un petit
peu de la capi notre action là il ya du
tirage de cheveux donc la pomme de pin
qui évoque prise d'une façon telle qu'on
ne peut que évoquer la suite de
fibonacci évidemment parce que encore
une fois on ne parle pas on ne parle pas
et le terrorisme sans parler nombre d'or
j'aimerais bien aller je veux attirer
votre attention sur le caractère tout à
fait fibonacci lien de cette glande
pinéale déjà que la ressemblance à une
pomme de pain et pas évidentes alors si
en plus on se met à rajouter de la suite
de fibonacci là dedans on va pas s'en
sortir et on retrouve aussi devant la
maison de certains illuminatis lâche
francs-maçons bahreïn mais comme le
monde entier et franc-maçon d'après lui
c'est quoi c'est la maison de 10
d'ailleurs c'est bien gentil de nous
dire que c'est une maison de francs
maçons jamais commenter comment on sait
c'est la maison qu'ils aient après la
plus grande statue du vatican est une
grosse pomme de pain va très bien en
mieux je connais pas la symbolique
catholique pour savoir ce que la pomme
de pin représente chez eux donc je vais
croire sur parole en quand unis que
c'est de bien qu'on à terre et le ciel
mais bon si vous voulez croire que tous
les croyants depuis des millénaires voue
un culte aux pommes de pin c'est vous
qui voyez
parce que croire que les croyants voue
un culte à un organe atrophiée dans
votre cerveau c'est moins qu'on peut
être question quelles sont les fonctions
admise par la communauté scientifique de
nos jours au sujet de la glande pinéale
hall à l'âge de 15 ans la glande pinéale
qui se situe au milieu de notre cerveau
est indispensable à notre survie à notre
développement cérébral
elle crée la sérotonine qui est une
hormone qui produit l'état de sommeil
donc la grande
elle a plusieurs fonctions dont la
fonction première étant de produire la
mélatonine
donc voilà sérotonine un produit
probablement de la sérotonine
mais sa fonction première c'est la
mélatonine est la mélatonine à la
plusieurs fonctions la plus important
est de moduler le les cycles du sommeil
donc ça on est d'accord là dessus donc
il a confondu probablement sérotonine et
mélatonine déjà de balade aux flambeaux
c'est pas beau du tout ensuite
ensuite il ya une régulation donc de la
glande pituitaire qui est elle même
produit l'hormone de croissance donc
effectivement la glande pinéale est
indispensable à notre développement
pas seulement cérébrale à notre
développement tout court qui puisqu'elle
a influencé la glande pituitaire est
donc l réguler le métabolisme des eaux
et elle régule aussi de nombreux cycles
du nombre de cycles biologiques pas
seulement le cycle du sommeil
donc on peut aller taper sérotonine pour
aller voir sur la page sérotonine
wikipedia nous dit que la sérotonine est
sécrétée par la glande pinéale recherche
signalent lumière points il n'ya point
de mention de la glande pinéale sur la
page sérotonine donc félicitations
article tu viens de te planter c'est pas
la sérotonine c'est la mélatonine
elle crée la dmt diméthyltryptamine qui
est une drogue puis produisant les rêves
des drogues produisent près les rêves en
rien une drogue qui produit des rêves
cesser nos neurones qui produisent les
rêves
1 c'est pas la drogue la dmt relâcher
toutes les nuits pour produire nos rêves
vision a évidemment la dmt est aussi
relâché en masse lors du passage vers la
dmt est aussi relâché en masse lors du
passage vers la mort du corps eh ben on
va demander sa internet
puisqu'on est
ah les bras font d'internet et on va
prendre votre ip diable parce qu'on va
pas aller chercher plus tard parce que
j'imagine que si c'est le blé cissé est
l'objet d'un culte est noté rich couple
biochemical suisse army knife
ça veut dire que la dmt a fait plein de
trucs donc en l'occurrence peut être pas
la bonne idée d'aller du côté de la dmt
pour pour avoir un la dmt elle est
relâchée dans beaucoup de situations
était pas seulement la mort cérébrale
quoi donc la dmt on va simplifier les
choses on va directement taper finale
dans l'onglet de recherche voilà en 2013
des chercheurs ont pour la première fois
reporté de la dmt dans la glande pinéale
des rongeurs donc providing alors
montrant ainsi donc c'est à peu près la
même phrase mais avec rajouter montrant
qu' il n'ya de la dmt endogène dans le
cerveau des mammifères
donc apparemment c'est pas le centre
c'est pas l'endroit où on n'en produit
plus fine et a visiblement de la dmt
dans produit ailleurs on en produit
ailleurs entre autres la glande pinéale
mais bon au dessus il ya quand même il
ya quand même un endroit où j'ai bien vu
qu'on avait de l'adn la tnt dans les
urines aussi donc a priori on en a
partout dans le corps de la réalité il
ya plusieurs endroits où la dnt et
produisent ce n'est pas seulement la
glande pinéale donc déjà quelles sont
les fonctions a misé par la communauté
scientifique de nos jours au sujet de la
glande pinéale d'un pourcent correct ne
se plie pas un sachant que c'est un
paragraphe de cinq lignes
c'est quand même dommage d'avoir que 20%
correct sur cinq lignes
oui je précise je suis un connard
extrêmement condescendant et j'ai
l'intention de le rester
voilà ça ça ne changera pas j'ai vu j'ai
vu beaucoup de commentaires sur
sur les derniers des bonnes kg pénitence
qui se plaignait que j'étais trop
condescendant avec envers les articles
et les auteurs des articles que je des
bunkers je crois que vous avez raté le
but de l'émission d'ellen kg pénitence
des bonnes kg pénitence c'est la
violence donc on vous apprend à faire
les choses bien et quand vous les fait
mal il y à chati mans ces deux facettes
d'une même pièce qui s'appelle
l'éducation donc voilà on fait des
gentils vidéo où on n'est pas
condescendant et on explique gentiment
aux gens ce qui est correct est ce qu'il
n'est pas et je fais des grosses vidéos
très sale comme des bunkers gp dit ans
où je suis un odieux konarka
condescendant c'est la côte c'est le
côté châtiment après chacun gère la
quantité de châtiment comme il veut
personnellement je pense pas en faire de
trop elle veut dire on a fait quand même
de dire notre premier des bonnes cage
violent ça a été notre 100e vidéo c'est
des langages de stop en france justement
bon on avait fait la critique de l'atlas
de la création d'arômes yahia avant mais
très honnêtement enfin il le vaut bien
quoi cet atlas de la création le valait
bien
quand même donc on continue avec notre
glande pinéale pourquoi et comment
détartrer votre glande pinéale ah bah ça
aurait été intéressant déjà d'établir
avant en quoi elle est entartré notre
blonde pinéale qu'est-ce que vous
sous-entendez par détartrer une glande
pinéale ce que ça veut dire que vous
tous sachant que c'est un organe à
profit est ce que ça veut dire qu'on va
le d'elisa trophy non on va muscler
notre glande pinéale je ne sais pas j'ai
pas encore lu le paragraphe alors
peut-être que c'est plus sérieux que ça
mais là il ya des tarterêts votre glande
pinéale et là je vois un dentifrice à
l'une naturel de payer le bien est ce
que vous avez l'intention de vous
brosser la glande pinéale avec du
dentifrice juge
le composant chimique e-velop la glande
pinéale est le fluorure ou fluoride en
anglais wikipedia
dis moi c'est le plus haut qu'elle
contient pas son autre grande finale
fluor alors maintenant on est plus
heureux la calcification de la glande
pinéale est typique des jeunes adultes
ababord tiens voilà ça c'est le
paragraphe qui manquait avant de dire
qu'il faut des tarterêts sa grande
minérale voilà vous montrer qu'il ya une
calcification je crois que ce détartrage
de la glande pinéale c'est une mauvaise
traduction de décalque de
décalcification de sa glande pinéale
donc voilà m et ça voudrait dire qu'il y
aurait quelque chose de sérieux dans ce
top mensonge
attention là là je suis prêt à me
convertir une suprême convertir alors la
calcification de la glande pinéale est
typique des jeunes adultes
il a été observé chez les enfants de 2
et elle a été observée chez les enfants
de 2 ans le dépôt de calcium et du
phosphore sur la glande pinéale est
corrélée à l'âge
quand on vieillit la glande pinéale
contient à peu près le seul le même
quantité de fluor que les dents donc la
quantité de fluor pinéale et la quantité
de calcium finale sont corrélés donc il
ya autant de personnes
il n'y a pas autant de calcium mais les
deux les deux contenus tv remis ensemble
ah mais c'est intéressant donc il ya
beaucoup de fluor dans la glande pinéale
effectivement dont elle a tendance à se
qualifier naturellement visiblement donc
la glande calcifié souvent visibles sur
les rayons x avec la calcification
varient beaucoup d'un pays à l'autre et
est corrélée avec l'âge la qualification
étant présentes chez 40% des américains
à l'âge de 16 ans la calcification de la
glande pinéale est associée au corps
okoor arenas et qui est aussi connue et
peu soutenu comme le monde sous le nom
de sable du cerveau en gros il semble
que la sécrétion interne de la glande
pinéale bloque le développement des
organes des glandes reproductrices quand
elle et quand elle est très endommagée
chez les enfants le développement des
organes sexuels et le skinhead sont
accélérées quelques études montrent que
deux sets 4-6 fication de la glande
pinéale et plus haut chez les patients
avec alzheimer que dans les autres types
de démence la calcification pourrait
contribuer aux autres pathogène de la
maladie d'alzheimer ce qui pourrait
refléter une absence de l'inhibiteur de
cette cristallisation la calcification
de la grande finale est aussi trouvé est
aussi étroitement associés à certains
types de migraine et des maux de tête
petit ellipses parce que du coup j'ai
voulu vérifier ces histoires de quel
calcification alors effectivement la
qualifie donc contrairement à ce que
j'ai dit tout à l'heure la calcification
du coup ne régresse pas donc je ne sais
pas ce qu'ils ont voulu dire par cette
phrase comme quoi la classification est
typique des jeunes adultes en réalité la
calcification elle augmente quand on
vieillit donc comme l'indiquent cette
magnifique image issue d'un article
disponible ce risque gates donc un
article peer review tout ce qui est plus
sérieux donc on voit des radiographies
du cerveau vous voyez la glande pinéale
au milieu avec l'âge qui augmente donc
de zéro à 51 ans c'est une personne de
55 ans ça c'est une personne de 60 ans
on voit la glande pinéale ici 67 et la
74 donc une belle qualification
effectivement de la glande pinéale bomba
le truc c'est que je vois pas vraiment
quelles sont les conséquences en fait
you're in concédant qu'il y aurait des
conséquences notables sur la maladie
d'alzheimer
mais au final avec cette question du
comment des tarterêts votre grand prix
il faudrait d'abord vous expliquer le
pourquoi mais justement le pourquoi fait
aussi partie de ce chef de ce petit
paragraphe donc maintenant j'aimerais
bien savoir pourquoi je devrais départ
fait ma glande pinéale sachant qu'il ya
des gens qui vivent jusqu'à 74 ans avec
la glande pinéale la plus en portrait du
monde
le composant chimique qui bloque la
glande pinéale et le fluorure ou fiori
dans l'anglais et le fluorure est
utilisé dans tous les dentifrices et
ajouter dans toutes les eaux de robinet
mais aussi en bouteille
elle est injectée dès l'enfance à nos
enfants par les laboratoires
pharmaceutiques aux mairies les big
pharmas ccc comme l'article précédent
c'est nos grands quinté+ de là le grand
café plus des théories ésotérique que
slash complotistes quoi c'est le vatican
les illuminati les francs maçons les
francs maçons qui affiche devant leur
maison qu'il faut entartré la glande
pinéale de vos enfants avec les
laboratoires pharmaceutiques
oui mais encore une fois j'ai la photo
d'une femme qui a vécu qui a 74 ans
quand elle passe sa radio elle a vécu
avec une glande pinéale bien dans ta
retrait et a certainement encore vécu
après donc je sais pas faudrait voir le
taux d'entartrage de la filiale de gm
qu'alban je ne pense pas que ça a été
que ça a été regardée mais a priori on
peut vivre avec une cuillère lanta
retrait alors pourquoi tout de suite
faire appel pourquoi tu veux tout de
suite me faire peur avec un laboratoire
pharmaceutique des pharmas complot et
tout ça avant même de m'avoir expliqué
si oui ou non c'était dangereux d'avoir
la glande pinéale entartré calcifié en
l'occurrence parfait elle est injectée
dès l'enfance à nos enfants par les
laboratoires pharmaceutiques à un tintin
qui font les dentifrices ainsi que l'eau
les jus de fruits et les sodas ben oui
les sodas d'efforts laboratoires
pharmaceutiques
l'eau utilisée dans les boissons et
effectivement la compagnie de l'eau
fait partie des laboratoires
pharmaceutiques on avait oublié de lire
ce lot utilisé dans les boissons à base
de jus ou soda est évidemment l'eau la
moins chère pour se faire un max de blé
donc de l'eau contenant du fluorure qui
bloque vos capacités cérébrales
alors la moins chère pour se faire un
max de blé stock mensonge 2018 la moins
chère pour se faire un max de blé
hu voilà la logique des gens qui
écrivent ces articles oui donc le grand
complot mais moi dès que je lis complot
de toute façon je vous lis plus en fait
donc non moi je veux savoir pourquoi
c'est dangereux
avant de me faire peur dites moi
pourquoi c'est dangereux vous pouvez
trouver dans des magasins spécialisés
des dentifrices en fluor moi même je
n'utilise plus que ça personnellement
quand je vois un placement produit comme
ça je ne m'inquiète pas c'est encore une
fois le cas il ya deux poids deux
mesures c'est à dire qu'on nous dit nana
les groupes pharmaceutiques est et où il
nous polluent notre honolulu et de soda
ou encore comment les pharmaceutiques
auraient accès à volutes ruivo troué
look sodas mais admettons
c'est un grand complot tout le monde est
de mèche et derrière on vous met un
placement produit by the way ça
ressemble un peu à un dollar mac
incitation à la peur 1 6 tonne
incitation à la peur suivi d'un
placement produit et ça deviendrait de
n'importe où ailleurs tout le monde se
méfierait mais comme ça vient de
quelqu'un qui dit mais les laboratoires
pharmaceutiques alors là c'est propre
nom ce trop facile moi je dis que c'est
trop facile alors encore une fois je
pense que c'est un article traduit
d'ailleurs donc slope mensonge y est
probablement pour rien pas directement
je veux dire même et non le lien si ici
si vous méfier du même type de message
quand ils viennent
de n'importe où ailleurs mais que quand
ça vient de stop aux mensonges qui vous
vie les laboratoires pharmaceutiques
sont pas gentils acheté mon dentifrice
je suis désolé moi je me méfie tout
autant pour retrouver vos capacités
cérébrales avaient été tous les sodas et
les jus à base de concentré doha ajouté
changer de dentifrice également cet
impératif
tu n'as toujours pas expliquer en quoi
la calcification la glande pinéale
altérer les capacités cérébrales
explique nous pourquoi
pourquoi c'est là pourquoi alors situé à
réponse à ton pourquoi ces pourris vives
pour retrouver vos capacités cérébrales
je suis désolé il ya peut-être fallu
établir en quoi altérer les capacités
cérébrales
alors on va peut-être aller chercher sur
internet nous mêmes du coup parce que
dieu c'est certainement pas là qu'on va
les trouver les réponses
on va éviter tous les sites et de
exotérique adorons la jusqu'à présent
tout ce qu'on a établi c'est que la
glande pinéale à la calcification de la
glande pinéale aurait peut-être un effet
sur sur la maladie d'alzheimer
peut-être place à un article sur les
tumeurs donc il y a un taux de 4,6
fication de 100% de la pinéale dans les
cas de germinon mme de par contre il est
très bas dans les cas de terreau atone
quelle est la différence géant mineur d
un tératome les pirates home c'est
réussi cesser ces tumeurs un peu
dégueulasse dans lesquels on trouve des
dents des poils des cheveux enfin des
muscles de l'os et donc ils peuvent ou
ne peuvent être trouvés aussi dans la
glande pinéale donc il ya différents
types de tumeurs des germinaux mais les
terrains at home et les germyn sommes
comme des terres at home peuvent être
bénins ou mal à parler lettera tome sont
plus souvent bénins qu'autre chose
à moins qu'ils prennent vraiment trop de
plastiques se met à faire n'importe quoi
je crois que les germes innove c'est ce
qu'on appelle plus couramment les
cancers
tu meurs de tout germe une homme est
uniforme et c'est elle est pleine de
cellules voilà que reproduit à longueur
de temps donc le germinal c'est vraiment
le cancer tels compellent qu'on en parle
c'est la tumeur cancéreuse tel qu'on en
parle encore peu comme comme il était
critique certains se menacer un
pensionnat voilà voilà
là au moins on trouve pourquoi des
calcifié sa glande pinéale parce que la
glande pinéale et la calcification de la
glande pinéale serait impliqué en partie
dans la maladie d'alzheimer elle serait
en tout cas elle l'a elle et elle est
près de plus prépondérant de chez les
malades d'alzheimer est ce que c'est une
cause ou une conséquence c'est pas mes
banques doute pourquoi pas pourquoi pas
vouloir des qualifiés sa glande pinéale
et elle est aussi prépondérante dans les
cas de tumeurs bénignes ou malignes
voilà encore une fois qu'on en
conséquence on ne sait pas mais voilà ça
vaut le coup ça vaut le coup de se
méfier
voilà voilà plutôt que dire de faire feu
roland et de dire vous allez perdre vos
capacités cérébrales et tout ça je veux
dire tu as raison tu as raison venu pour
une fois un plutôt que d'essayer de nous
vendre pour dentifrice à lui l'essentiel
est de vouloir faire peur aux gens avec
des complots à dos rond et dinard voilà
la pinéale et plus souvent qualifiés
chez les malades d'alzheimer et dans les
cas de cancer voilà en restant vague
voilà sur le fait que c'est plutôt une
cause ou une conséquence
et puis voilà tu as ton truc qu'on crut
que du soutien scientifique des arias ça
m'a pris quatre secondes à trouver quoi
bref on continue vous voulez à jus de
fruits pressés vos fruits ou opter pour
de l'organique encore une fois bang
l'organique vous verrez la différence au
bout de trois à six semaines vous n'en
reviendrez pas si spectaculaires voilà
là on est vraiment sur de la pub c'est
de la pub à ce niveau là c'est moche là
où vous noterez le plus de changements
c'est aussi dans vos rêves vous mettrez
à mieux vous rappelez de vos rêves et
révéré à nouveau en couleurs
c'est sûr que si tu étais addict au mcdo
et que d'un seul coup tu te mets à boire
des jus de fruits pressés et à bouffer
organique c'est clair qu'il va y avoir
une amélioration dans ta de gestion et
du coût qualité de consommer y voilà la
découverte de l'action blocs lente
qualifiante du fluorure sur la glande
pinéale a été fait dans la deuxième
guerre mondiale par les chercheurs
d'hitler parce que hitler manqué à
l'équation t'avais est avait acquis un
semblant de crédibilité il ya quinze
secondes et tu viens de tout [ __ ] en
l'air en allant le chercher
hitler pourquoi pourquoi tu avais
presque gagné mon respect quoi elle a
été alors utilisé dans les camps de
concentration pour maintenir les
prisonniers docile et need leur a refilé
le tuyau soviétique qui leur à leur tour
l'ont utilisé sur leur peuple à très
grande échelle en admettant dans l'eau
du robinet je crois vous dansez falot g
y'a quoi en dessous de encéphalogramme
plat
est ce que l'on est ce qu'on avance est
ce qu'on peut avoir dansé falot gram
négatif quoi mondiale la découverte de
l'action bloquante alors autant autant
la calcification aurait un effet aurait
une corrélation avec alzheimer aurait
une corrélation avec le cancer de la
glande pinéale je veux bien mais mais
l'action bloquante sur notre dans le
comportement c'est une glande la glande
pinéale c'est une glandes qui sécrètent
la mélatonine allah veut dire si ça
devait avoir la moindre conséquence ce
serait sur la qualité de votre sommeil
si tous après la glande pinéale elle a
un effet aussi sur les cycles
reproducteurs sont tous les cycles
biologiques le plus important d'entre
eux étant aussi que reproducteur donc
dans ce cas là je trouve pas ça
surprenant que la glande se qualifie
avec l'âge puisque puisque la
reproduction
laissez vos chances de reproduction sont
avides de toute façon donc [ __ ] en
l'air vous aussi que reproducteur n'aura
pas un grand effet mais les l'action
bloquant sur le comportement ça rend les
gens dociles mais en quoi
en quoi c'est une glande les mecs on
parle pas de votre cortex cérébral c'est
pas votre cortex préfrontal la glande
pinéale c'est pas là que se prennent vos
décisions c'est pas de règle en pin et
elle que ça se prend les décisions ça
c'est juste une langue de dire wahaha
le raccourci de l'enfer qui tu veux dire
le pire c'est que j'étais j'étais
presque en train de dire il a raison
c'est vrai que dans l'absolu si le fluor
vous pourrez votre glande pinéale
effectivement c'est bien de diminuer
votre consommation de fluor en
consommant par exemple moins d'eau du
robinet éventuellement mais encore que
je ne sais pas s'il a encore du fluor
dans l'eau du robinet tenant ça vaut le
coup d'aller les acheter plus hors eau
du robinet sans et 10 passes et la
fluoration encore campo en france est-ce
qu'on fluor encore là l'eau en france la
fluoration volontaire n'est plus
pratiquée depuis la fin des années 80 le
complot départ mais sutil qui veulent
nous faire croire qu'ils ont arrêtés
moreno ils veulent nous faire croire
qu'ils ont arrêté plus aurait l'eau ces
[ __ ] et ce alors elle s'est redit si
bon oui donc je disais limitons notre
consommation de fluor pourquoi pas c'est
vrai qu'il ya une époque où on voulait
fluorés les dentifrices comme des
sauvages et en rajouter des données aux
enfants des suppléments couleur en plus
du reste et puis c'est vrai qu'on
finisse et juste avec des taches sur les
dents parce que moi parce que le fluor
s'attachent les dents
donc finalement c'est pas si efficace
que ça au final donc ça marche pas ça
permet pas tant que ça d'éviter les
caries dentaires
mais dans l'absolu j'étais plus ou moins
d'accord effectivement s'initient à
allier avec alzheimer ci aurait un lien
avec alzheimer s'il y aurait un lien
avec les cancers vous était d'accord
dans l'absolu
mais là à l'activité de nos cordes quoi
ça vous empêche de prendre des décisions
dont ces glandes pinéale seeland qui
sécrètent de la mélatonine ces pauvres
cortex quoi il faut arrêter un peu et
minerve hitler nucléaire à partir du
moment où s est pas un point godwin
d'ailleurs voilà qu'on va partir du
moment où on à thann la citation
d'hitler ces cons et qu'on a atteint le
fond du fond de l'argumentation quoi
donc quand les américains ont mené
l'opération paperclip à la fin de la
guerre faites vos recherches sur ces
mots clés ils sont tombés sur ces
recherches et les ont utilisés à leur
tour sur leur population
mais eux ils y ont ajouté l'aspect
pratique et financier ils sont forts ces
ricains plutôt que de payer eux-mêmes
pour l'ajout du fluor et sa distribution
il vous ils ont eu l'idée de le faire a
ajouté à des pâtes dentifrices de
manière assez content à ce qu'ils soient
payés par nous les esclaves et distribué
par les laboratoires pharmaceutiques en
y ajoutant un passage obligé dans
l'enseignement secondaire collèges pour
apprendre petit pet boom combien c'est
important de bien se brosser les dents
avec du dentifrice au fluor
depuis tous les gouvernements du monde
utilisent le bon vieux poisson poison à
rat dans l'eau et dentifrice qui
contient cinq mille fois qui en contient
cinq mille fois plus que dans l'eau
ouais sauf que ça c'est du fluorure de
sodium ça le fluor qui est mis dans
l'eau c'est de lyon fluor ses skis et
lila à nyon fluorure l'addition
artificielle est contrôlée non plus hors
sûrs et puis ils ont utilisé le fluo
rose silicate de sodium où existe le
fluo rose silicate de sodium de l'acide
hexafluorure les appelait aussi à ses
plus hauts rossi silicique pardon à ses
victimes
c'est pas attendez c'est pas facile à
dire quoi le fluoro silicate de sodium
de l'acide hexafluorure signifique donc
furent silicate de sodium
la formule s'est elle a deux sf6 on
formule du poison pour la mort aux rats
c'est cet écrit nulle part
bon on va écrire se dire une torride
sodium fluoride pardon il ya eu voilà
sodium fluoride n as le fluo rossi li
kath n a de sf 6 bon ça n'a rien à voir
bon d'accord il ya une fluor d'accord il
ya du silicium mais globalement sanaa ça
n'a pas du tout la même formule chimique
pas victime du tout donc merci met à
mort tu auras tu coûtes la mettre au
vote schiller ouais donc voilà c'est non
c'est pas de la mort aux rats qu'on met
dans l'eau voilà merci d'avoir essayé
mais c'est raté
pas convaincu les glande pinéale des
humains sont tellement calcifié de nos
jours dans les sociétés modernes que
leur dédié au vin le cerveau le petit
point blanc que vous voyez au milieu
dans tous les radios c'est la glande
pinéale calcifié oui bah on est vieux
c'est bien failli majine que du coup
s'il ya une offre une consommation
excessive de fluor il peut certaines
périodes de l'histoire entre les années
50 et années 80 effectivement quand tu
vas faire des irm de personnes âgées
aujourd'hui elles vont avoir une plante
pinéale vachement calcifié donc ça la
vie nietzsche de l'admettre
plein de gens de mon entourage me
prennent pour un fou quand je leur dis
que les gens pour qui une botte de tous
bords les prennent pour des cons leur
manque du matin au soir et cherchent à
les tuer mais on réfléchit cherchent à
les tuer vous êtes des villes où quoi
dire les impôts qui c'est qui les payent
les impôts les gens pour qui tu votes
une vive sur tes impôts ils vont pas
chercher à te tuer
alors qu'encore le passage où ils
essayent de 30 docile avec du fluor bien
que je vois pas où est le lien entre la
docilité et fluor
admettons mais qui cherche à te tuer
dans ta gueule
ta gueule plein de gens demandent je
pense je pense en avoir apporté la
preuve ici
alors voici la preuve de quoi il pense
avoir apporté ce sont des criminels et
leur place est en prison
ah bon bon non plus non enfin le lien
entre la calcification et donc des
maladies dégénératives telles
qu'alzheimer le cancer c'est moi qui les
fais c'est moi qui suis allé chercher
sur internet
donc tu as fait la preuve d'un regain
connard de tous de plus ce ne sont pas
eux qui nous gouvernent ce sont des
marionnettes aux mains des illuminati
qui nous voient nous les esclaves comme
des cafards et tous les médias sont
leurs complices car leur d'agents leurs
agents provient de leur argent provient
des publicités détenus par les
multinationales
elle même détenue par les illuminati
elle même détenue par des
multinationales elles mêmes par elle
même détenue par des reptiliens et des
extra terrestres et des poulpes
voilà donc tu nous as fait la preuve que
tu étais paranoïaque
ça me suis d'accord que tu voit des
complots partout avant même d'argumenter
sur le fond scientifique de ce que tu
dis ça ça j'ai vu ça ça j'ai vu parce
que le pire c'est que tu as raison sur
certains points il ya au moins quelques
phrases qui sont pas trop conne dans ton
article
et le pire c'est que tu ne connais même
pas rendu compte tellement tu était
obsédé par conte par contre délire
paranoïaque et si vous croyez que les
élites ne sont pas au courant c'est que
vous n'avez toujours rien compris
moi j'ai plus la télé depuis longtemps
je vais me mettre à lire avec une voix
d'enfant a tardé voyez plus la télé
depuis bien longtemps et je m'en porte
bien mieux ou au moins qu'ils ne
contribuent pas leur système de contrôle
mental car mes enfants sont élevés comme
des humains libres et à l'esprit ouvert
et critique il est temps de se réveiller
et ainsi je mets et ainsi je mets une
vidéo sur la troisième âge qui provient
de youtube comme le premier comme le dit
ce logo or qui est possible qu'ils
essaient youtube bête mais c'est google
et google c'est quoi c'est une grande
compagnie illuminati
dans ta vidéo est sponsorisé par les
ennemis natif c'est pas faux que j'en
déduis squale puissance air déduire quoi
du fait que tu partages une vidéo google
un bon allez regardons la 4 minutes
ouais on va la regarder la glande
pinéale voilà c'est tout imagination est
plus importante que le savoir j'ai
presque envie d'aller voilà aussi
passion
voilà des fausses citations de la mouche
times je n'ai jamais dit la moitié des
conneries que les gens croient que jésus
voilà non c'est la petite blague c'est
le petit troll voilà l'imagination c'est
quoi sa phrase remet moi ça te plaît
l'imagination la plus importante que le
savoir parce que c'est vraiment une
imagination et une importante que le
savoir enjoy le wiki côte le recueil de
citations libre
imagina toute imagination citation
attribuée à einstein
l'imagination est plus importante que le
savoir le savoir est limité alors que
l'imagination englobe le monde entier
stimule le progrès suscite l'évolution
qui a été écrite donc en 1929 c'est bien
une steinbruch une fois pour une fois
c'est une citation d'einstein qui n'est
pas complètement fous plus on prête
attention aux coïncidences plus elles se
produisent
vladimir nabokov pour l'instant rien de
très pin et à elle dans tout ça
aliou bah oui mais comment tu veux que
j'arrive à admire ce film et ce à chaque
fois à l'âne diouf dans son livre
souligne l'importance de la langue
française car elle peut dissimuler des
coïncidences remarquable le secret de
gagnant alors on est à 30 secondes sur
une vidéo quatre minutes
pour l'instant il n'a rien à voir avec
la glande pinéale 0 par contre il ya une
musique spirituelle donc fatalement keny
arkana le soleil est en toi ce brillait
ta lumière intérieure
voilà mange une lampe manger une ampoule
de quel soleil elle nous parle observé
le mot soleil et trouver les mots qui
s'y cachent ça brûle le soleil le soleil
ah mais oui d'accord maintenant j'ai la
logique donc voilà le mot soleil
ressemble ou deux mots soleil voilà dans
la langue française
d'où la citation de la langue française
par alan dukes langue française cachent
des coïncidences remarquable et oui elle
s'était c'était subtil c'est est subtile
mais personne n'a vu venir de là donc
voilà bon évidemment en anglais ça
marche moins bien the sun d'avoir
beaucoup moins bien stargate
il ya un oeil dans la stargate il ya des
filets l'image d'anouilh dans la farine
ceci n'est pas l'emplacement de la
véritable glande pinéale
rené descartes la glande pinéale et le
siège de l'amdh encore non pas la bride
dernier commet des anciens référence aux
anciens corps c'est vieux c'est quand
c'est vieux c'est sérieux les anciens
connaissaient le secret de la glande
pinéale et l'ont transmis par l'écriture
lâche l'architecturé les symboles pas
ils l'ont mis dans l'architecturé les
symboles et pourquoi il n'a jamais écrit
clairement comment on devait s'en servir
c'est dommage je suis presque sûr que ça
ressemble pas à ça les pyramides de
gizeh ou pyramides ou pyramide ça
ressemble à une longue finale
on a bien vu le dernier un petit tas de
cellules bad man triangulaire 500 la
glande pinéale voilà la pyramide se
superposent parfaitement au cerveau
humain est un magicien noir donc déjà
rien qu'à voir la photo on a envie de le
prendre au sérieux monsieur la glande
pinéale oui au moins t'as pas oublier de
la m contrairement au schéma précédent
où il y avait l'oeil d'horus et oui
l'oeil d'horus ressemble à la couronne
les égyptiens waouh coïncidence la scène
avec jésus-christ ne ressemble à rien
voilà meilleur gardien et il ya zéro
contenu là on a deux minutes trente la
serre contenues dans cette vidéo
et puis là on nous dit hémisphère droit
hémisphère gauche donc en gros
l'hémisphère bois c'est la détente la
douceur le froid l'hiver le femina
l'hémisphère gauche c'est évidemment
c'est l'homme cedh aux chaussées damas
puis là c'est la peur la densité
l'attention la dureté le carré
l'entropie est évidemment leur tournée
elle fit l'air avec sa croix gammée fait
nan je sais bien que c'est un symbole
bouddhique mais quand même la vache
l'hémisphère droit les lycées reloger
j'imagine que la logique c'était au
milieu il ya la glande pinéale qui qui
nous bénit de seins de sa divine lumière
j'en sais rien j'essaye le soleil soleil
glande pinéale hémisphère gauche
hémisphère droit ou en bas mois sur des
sur des trucs comme ça je peux faire des
spéculations dans tous les sens
voilà donc au milieu au milieu il ya le
président de l'assemblée puis vous avez
les communistes et l'extrême droite
voilà moi aussi je peux faire des
interprétations perso c'est à l'âge de
33 ans que jésus est mort physiquement
qu'il est retourné dans les cieux et
ouais c'est là quel est le rapport
c'est à la mort de lego que de kundalini
peut s'élever jusqu'au proche jusqu'à la
trente troisième vertèbre ont branché
l'homme vertèbres prendre troisième
vertèbre par vertèbre rochette
est-ce qu'il faut vraiment que je
continue à élaborer sur comment ce genre
de vidéos qu'on prend pour un con parce
que là pour le coup venir le
gouvernement vous prend pour des cons
alors cette vidéo elle vous prend pour
un niveau au-dessus quoi un niveau mais
dix fois au dessus de la trente
troisième vertèbre donc afin d'atteindre
la glande pituitaire qui stimule croyais
que c'était la glande pinéale là tu nous
parles de la glande pituitaire atteinte
en est là c'est pas la vie c'est pas
parce que tu nous fais pas ci fais ta
connerie afin d'atteindre la glande
pituitaire qui stimule la glande pinéale
banon on a luxe est l inverse
en réalité c'est la glande pinéale qui a
un effet sur l'api twitter voilà oui la
connexion directe entre votre coccyx et
votre cerveau penser avec votre lutte
non je sais pas c'est quoi le message à
des messages ses chakras les chakras qui
ont donc tout à voir avec votre glande
pinéale puisque c'est le troisième oeil
qui nous pas si tu es là où vous pensez
qu'il est situé derrière nous le
rappelle donc on vous montre les chakras
sont vraiment vous expliquer en quoi
c'est pertinent pour votre raisonnement
est cool ça fait une fleur
il fait l'échec est un trip hop de
matrix parce qu'on nous parce que on ne
saurait on ne saurait terminer une vidéo
comme ça sans d'une grosse référence
dans matrix
pourquoi parce que ci dessous une copie
d'un autre article que j'ai trouvé sur
le web
évidemment c'est l'article dénicher un
vrai que je me promenais notre ami masta
ghosn veut nous a gentiment suggéré du
mois je suppose
est ce que c'est vraiment celui-là alors
un article de masta gombo c'est pourquoi
et comment pourquoi et comment pourquoi
et comment
oui comment quoi pourquoi et comment des
tartes et votre grand pin et à bierne
quelques rues ils le disent pourquoi et
comment détartrer votre grande dune et
l1 parce que là il nous a dit nous
pourquoi du comment en prenant du
dentifrice bio
effectivement c'est le même article
donc pourquoi et comment des tarterêts
votre borne unéal froid la glande
pinéale pourrait être la partie la plus
importante de votre système nerveux tout
anti il s'agit essentiellement d'une
antenne spirituel votre équipe à lens
ziggy troisième oeil ah ben voilà déjà
là c'est au moins il n'y a pas le
raccourci en disant que la glande
pinéale c'est le 3e c'est pas votre 3e
il est essentiel pour atteindre des
niveaux plus élevés de conscience tout
en restant dans un corps physique donc
je rappelle que le niveau élévation de
consciente du coup les sténoses dont al
et ouattara ils sont ils sont type taupe
ou élévation de conscience du la taille
du troisième union lasser c'est plus une
antenne là c'est la passe et les
paraboles du pôle et c'est nico la
glande pinéale se trouve au centre
géométrique du cerveau elle est creuse
est rempli d'un fluide contenant des
cristaux la classification fait en sorte
que les cristaux dans la glande
s'attache aux dépôts de minéraux acides
et cristaux ne peuvent plus exercer
leurs propriétés résolu minet ce qui est
vous les éliminez sens est une plante
d'une licence créée par la pression sur
certains sont liés
[Musique]
il ya une pression sur la glande pinéale
et elle fait de la lumière mais oui bah
oui les effets de la calcification sont
la dépression d'anxiété la boulimie
anorexie la schizophrénie et d'autres
formes de maladie mentale ce qui n'est
rien de ce qu'on nous avons trouvé sur
google scholar la calcification il est
aussi perturbé la sécrétion de la
mélatonine bon à la limite je suis
d'accord la mélatonine souvent dénommé
hormone du sommeil est surtout connu
comme étant l'hormone central de la
régulation des rythmes chronobiologiques
d'un certain point de vue de
pratiquement l'ensemble des sécrétions
hormonales
elle est sécrétée par la glande pinéale
en réponse à l'absence de lumière la
mélatonine semble avoir des fonds de
multiples fonctions autres core model en
particulier comme antioxydant anticancer
elle semble aussi joué un rôle dans le
système immunitaire
il ya pas de références mais admettons
non pas comment la mélatonine pour
iphone anticancer à la limite par
antioxydants chez google scholar revient
à moi antioxydantes capacitive
mélatonine donc apparemment des articles
de la thur donc voilà finalement
j'aurais peut-être dû commencer par
relish et ça fait moins mal à la gueule
quoi si beaucoup moins de conneries
l'image de mon le dieu à hélécine herria
enki avec un cône un cône de pas dans la
main on trouve dans beaucoup de cultures
symbolique le cône de parents présentant
la glande pinéale siège de l'âme on
classifie casse la calcification de la
glande pinéale est causé principalement
par le fluorure qui circulent dans
l'autre sens le fluorure vient dé pâte à
dent de l'homme de l'onu robin et de
l'eau en bouteille dans certains
aliments les médicaments psychotropes
comme le prozac et qui est appelé plus
objective et qui contient prendre
conscience fluorure la glande pinéale
contient la plus grande concentration
plus rude dans le corps calcification
malheureusement pour la plupart des gens
là gameplay à proprement par très forte
si bien qu'elle apparaît comme un
morceau de calcium laure duny havane
alors qu'elle est là 4,6 alors qu'elle
est la calcification et quelles sont les
causes ou ça aussi ça ressemble à de la
traduction un peu barbare d'autant que
comme le leader il ya plus de fluor dans
l'eau du robinet en france donc
donc ça sent la traduction barbares
encore une fois d'un article en anglais
la calcification et l'accumulation de
cristaux de phosphate de calcium dans
diverses parties du corps vous croyez
qu'on parlait de fluorure pourquoi tu
parles pas aussi c'est un processus
naturels causés par les laines aux
bactéries melli les bactéries sont des
micro organismes qui forment le
minuscule coquilles d'oeufs constate de
personnes autour d'eux essentiellement
pour se protéger de votre système
immunitaire
il ressort de la dernière recherche que
cela peut être la cause de la plupart
des maladies de l'arthrite aux accidents
vasculaires cérébraux
cancer aux maux de dos il va ce système
immunitaire et seul alimentaire s à des
standards de résine horrible la plupart
des gens sont exposés à beaucoup plus
ces organismes que jamais et que non
seulement est que non seulement sont
qualifiés par d'autres moyens aussi dire
voyez plus au moins vous relire quoi
alors les nanos bactéries primé liste
parce qu'il faut pas de la faire à
l'envers qu'est ce que c'est
apparemment ça n'existe pas non bacteria
prix mais toujours à rien ça n'existe
pas les nanos bacteria prix mérite donc
encore une fois je pense qu'il
s'agissait en réalité du maupuy marine
du mot anglais prix mariné et que la
france était donc c'est un processus
naturel causée principalement par les
nanos bactéries non pas par des nano
bactérie appelée pluie mêlée donc là il
ya un gros souci de réduction
donc c'est pour ça que ça a l'air d'être
un mot de français donc nano bacteria m
pagnol calcification donc qu'est-ce
qu'on en fait même cet article ces
genres il ya qu une seule fois où le mot
pinéale et les cris et c'est dans la
conclusion quoi de reste pour tout le
reste
en gros c'est pas des anneaux bactéries
tous les faits des labos bactérie est
expliqué on a les enclaves voilà on a
les endroits où les nanos bactéries ont
effectivement un effet sur la
qualification des organes donc les reins
les os les le coeur et les poumons
doublement est donc le seul endroit où
le blanc ou le mot glande pinéale et
testé c'est dans les perspectives les
futurs vaut cher quand il faudra voir si
la glande pinéale et est affecté par ces
nano bactéries qualifiante
donc mon donc non non non la
calcification des calcifications n'ai
pas lu à d'elano bactéries dans la lande
mineurs du cas pas pour autant qu'on
sache ça reste à voir
par contre l'arthrite le d'accident
vasculaire est comme ça oui
éventuellement ça peut avoir une origine
jehanno bactéries
un conseiller de la qualifie de
l'application de la glande pinéale ça a
l'air d'être globalement un phénomène
naturel
alors mes principales causes de
calcification comprennent le fluorure
magnétiquement attirés par la glande
pinéale ou une forme des cristaux de
phosphate de calcium
plus que partout ailleurs dans le corps
le fluorure forme du phosphate de
calcium
oui oui oui
et puis quand tu mélanges du fer à de la
sueur ça fait des chocapics voilà c'est
à peu près autant de sens magnetic man
attirés par la glande pinéale le fluor
et magnétiques
bien sûr les suppléments de calcium de
loin la principale cause de
calcification si notre vestiaire vous
recommande de les prendre leurs
commandes d'arrêter immédiatement dit
oui parce que je suis plus intelligent
qu'un médecin qui a fait des années
d'études
oui parce que je suis un connard qui dit
aux gens qui recommande aux gens de ne
pas suivre des prescriptions médicales
civiles donc là en groupe
bonjour madame bonjour madame avec de
l'ostéoporose
arrêtez de prendre votre calcium vous
allez voir que ça ira mieux
oui mais oui d'autres halogénures comme
le chlore et le bromure le calcium dans
l'alimentation presque tous les aliments
transformés compagnie certaine forme de
calcium [ __ ] l'eau du robinet est
rempli de substances qualifiante et
l'eau de source distiller elle peut être
nocive à long terme même si c'est
beaucoup mieux que l'eau du robinet est
donc tu recommande à personne d'arrêter
de boire de l'eau du coup non mais
arrêtez de boire
vous verrez vous serez plus malade ou
c'est un peu mort nous sommes malades la
détox de la grande pie de la glande
pinéale la coriandre le magnésium
l'homéopathie évidemment les zéolites
nouvelle élite
excusez moi donc j'ai voulu faire
quelques recherches concernant du coup
c'est là nos bactéries et les côtes de
l'entartage de l'affiner aller pour
autant que j'ai pu trouver en gros il
n'y a pas vraiment de cause connue alors
partage de la lumière
vous avez un article de 2001 où on en
est explique qu'en gros on n'est plus à
établir si oui ou non l'entartrage
augmente quoi déjà au cours de la vie
idem pour celui là quoi donc on sait pas
exactement pas exactement en fait ce qui
se passe avec cette pile et alain j'ai
l'impression que c'est un peu un peu
c'est encore un peu mystérieux me
semblerait et on sait pas vraiment aussi
les conséquences que ça alors par
exemple l'article
il conclut en disant que ça peut avoir
un effet de peut-être lampard fans a un
effet sur les rôles c'est le rôle
sécréteurs de la glande pinéale et donc
sur la mélatonine sur la synthèse de la
mélanine notamment mais voilà il ses
hypothèses de fin d'article jeter comme
ça et pas vraiment il n'ya pas vraiment
de nocivité connu et puis comme je le
disais c'est un phénomène qui est
naturel là dans l'article en question
ils le disent que déjà des dés l'âge de
même avant l'âge de 6 ans déjà il ya ne
peut y avoir un phénomène ben arfa de
calcification de la glande pinéale donc
voilà je n'ai pas l'impression que qui
est deux raisons très objectif de
vouloir absolument lutter contre ça et
encore moins avec de l'homéopathie
je voulais vraiment lutter contre ça va
arrêter juste de koné pa du magnésium
quoi typiquement pourquoi pourquoi
prendre plus de minéraux mais parce que
même des hommes voilà pourquoi prendre
de plus de minéraux pour éviter à
d'entartrage le dire non c'est non donc
bon de l'argile veut dire tune en
prendre de l'argile pour éviter de
quelque chose fouteret de l'argile dans
ton dans les tuyaux pour empêcher
l'entartrage toi gros malin bon bref
donc l'article continue en conséquence
le nettoyage de votre corps de la
pollution par les métaux lourds et le
fluorure de sodium ne sera pas seulement
capable d'aider à normaliser votre
production de mélatonine mais permettra
également d'améliorer votre fonction
cognitive et d'augmenter vos
vitalité pour les fous pour la
production de mélatonine comme le disent
ses hypothèses en suspens les fonctions
cognitives et la vitalité comme j'ai dit
tout à l'heure ça n'a rien à voir avec
la pinéale ainsi si vos fonctions
cognitives étaient connectés directement
à votre vin idéal où elle le monde
serait dominée par les flots dont le nom
serait dominée par les toits tara et
leur troisième oeil gigantesque platon
descartes pythagore et bien d'autres
pensaient que la glande pinéale était le
siège de l'âme et ils ont eu tort
la langue pinéale à la forme d'un coup
de pinceau simple dans le coup ça montre
très bien qu'on est face à une
traduction barbare de l'anglais au
français ont une pomme dota pas une
conne c'est vraiment de l'anglais d'où
son nom
d'où son nom qui vient du latin pinet à
qui veut dire pas je n'accepte que
j'accepte cette analogie
techniquement la glande pinéale ne fait
pas partie du cerveau elle n'est pas
protégée par la barrière
hémato-encéphalique c'est vrai en fait
elle reçoit plus de sens que tous les
autres organes à l'exception des reins
comme elle n'est pas protégée du flux
sanguin
elle accumule des dépôts minéraux aussi
approuvé sable cérébrale l'accumulation
de l'accumulation de calcification n'a
rien à voir avec le fait qu'à l'époque
protégé du flux sanguin c'est peut-être
que elle-même joue le rôle de filtre
pour le cerveau éventuellement encore
que c'est pas ça fait pas partie de ses
fonctions reconnu mais voilà s'il
fallait chercher à une cause encore une
fois à ce cette qualification c'est pas
parce qu'à l'époque protégé du flux
sanguin c'est pas à cause des vanneaux
bactéries non plus en plus d'une
contredit la banque
bref avec le temps le sable s'accumuler
produit la classification de la glande
rendant au paquet disent que le fluide à
l'intérieur de la gueulante
admettons il est aussi connu que
l'intérieur de la glande pinéale
contient des cellules photosensibles
personnes la lumière on sait aussi que
c'est qu'elle est restée à l'intérieur
de la glande ont une propriété piezo
luminescents de piezo luminescence dont
on les ya plus de cellules
photosensibles dans la glande pinéale
humaine et surtout island puis
à lummen c'est probablement une des plus
petites de tout le règne animal et des
mini cristaux qui ont des propriétés
piezo luminescence oui j'imagine que
prise en laboratoire à part purifier et
soumis à une pression monumentale les
mêmes cristaux peuvent avoir une
propriété piezo luminescentes de là à
dire qu'il vous brille dans le cerveau
faut pas déconner ceci signifie que
lorsqu'on applique une pression sur les
cristaux et émettent de la lumière
voilà exactement des pignes elle brille
dans le noir on ne sera pas surpris
d'apprendre que dans la mythologie des
dykes on associe cette blombos troisième
oeil noter que la pinéale gère lé cycle
d'éveil et de sommeil c'est marrant
comme il associe la pinéale au troisième
elle est plus de par le fait
qu'effectivement la glande pinéale est
directement homologue au troisième oeil
de nos ancêtres les victimes à malien
c'est marrant ça irait tellement dans
leur sens de dire ça et pourtant je veux
dire il y a tellement de messages
il ya tellement d'articles scientifiques
et de véritables connaissances qui vont
dans le sens de leurs délires et dont
ils ne se servent pas si formidable
c'est ça aussi ça notre indice pour
reconnaître du bullshit c'est quand il
ya des raisons évidentes qui vous re
d'avoir raison mais qui les a pas juste
parce que ces faits par des scientifique
et que les scientifiques qui sont
méchants
on a découvert récemment qu'en fait la
glande pinéale est impuissant récepteur
mais que ce sont d'autres zones du
cerveau qui décolle qui décodent les
informations reçues telles que le cortex
frontal cérébrale sans cette interaction
les informations reçues ne pourrait pas
être comprise
elle joue un rôle vital au niveau du
sommeil et de la sexualité et donc de la
reproduction
oui je suis d'accord avec tout ce
paragraphe sauf sur le caucase récepteur
un récepteur de quoi c'est un puissant
récepteur alors impuissant récepteur
tout de suite on pense à une antenne
encore une fois il reçoit des ondes
électromagnétiques
bon avant tout en tant qu' en tant que
corgan c'est un récepteur d'hormones
c'est un récepteur de
deux signaux nerveux donc il y aurait
peut-être fallu voilà le côté puissant
récepteur je veux bien l'admettre enfin
récepteur du monde de tout de suite ce
que ça veut dire
dans ce contexte mais le côté récepteur
bah oui c'est un organe qui est connecté
aux autres organes donc c'est un
récepteur en secteur 2 100 d'hormones et
de messages nerveux et après le reste je
suis d'accord ça joue un rôle dans la
reproduction et la sexualité c'est
qu'ils associaient vous autres réseaux
terry qu'associé la sexualité à quelque
chose de formidable
en soi c'est choquant sexualité tous les
cycles si tous les cycles tous les
cycles vitaux sont plus ou moins
contrôlés par la mélatonine s'est fêté
par la glande pinéale pas seulement ici
pulsionnel donc je suis d'accord la
glande pinéale capte ainsi les
vibrations du spectre électromagnétique
bon dans les vibrations du spectre
électromagnétique ce sont vos yeux qui
décape
ça s'appelle de la lumière vibrations du
spectre électromagnétique c'est injuste
un grand rouleau dégueulasse pour dire
de la lumière et c'est dieu qui dit
qu'un pas votre glande pinéale parce que
votre glande pinéale n'est qu'une grande
elle n'est plus à photo rey s'est elle
n'est plus un organe photo réflecteurs
produisant nos émotions dans penser ou
celle des esprits voir celle d'autres
personnes au moyen de la télépathie donc
encore une fois les panneaux dont 1 ils
communiquent mais alors direct cerveau
cerveau télépathe l'esplanade on sait
qui a éveillé l'intérêt des
scientifiques qui ont mis à lui mis en
lumière des fonctions en relation avec
la physique et les phénomènes
paranormaux tels que les to ut france
médiumnique non ça va pas être des
scientifiques compétents ça m'étonnerait
les medium cap un grand nombre
d'informations prétendre qu'à fait un
grand nombre d'informations sur elles
évoluent ces informations sont
enregistrées par le peuple a museum du
cerveau qui l'aurait fait depuis dix ans
sans réel
accueil qu'on cortex a avant tout la
personne ne comprend pas beaucoup les
choses qu'elles captent mais son corps
ni réagi d'où le fait que les médiums
prétendent qu'ils étaient en nombre
d'informations la liste des réactions
que des combats par exemple représente
d'une âme errante avoir une sensation
dans la nuque maux de ventre emballement
du coeur fatigue soudaine sensation de
vertige demandé de l'argent pour avoir
capté quelque chose ça aussi c'est ainsi
médiumnique lors des états de
dédoublement que lui le médium celui ci
développe une plus grande activité
il capte les sensations d'autrui bah
écoute et encore une fois ci la glande
piscine le troisième oeil les
responsables de six activités meliani je
veux me faire pote avec des rythmes
d'ailleurs reptiles reptilien illuminati
je sais pas pourquoi j'ai fait j'ai pas
fait lire avant mais les yvelines a qui
doivent avoir une formidable une
formidable glande pinéale avec un
formidable troisième oeil accroché
dessus les personnes il est parfois
difficile pour le médium de distinguer
son sentiment individuel de celui qu'il
a pu capter des personnes peuvent alors
être confuse alors quand on quant à leur
propre identité
surtout si elles ignorent être médium ce
sont généralement des personnes
critiquent autocritique anxieuse var
dépressive voici votre horoscope
l'horoscope générique de la personne en
général vous êtes une personne vous avez
une personnalité critiques voire
autocritique
vous êtes souvent anxieux et dépressifs
et vous sentez parfois des prises
l'horoscope génériques
bonjour assieds toi là à côté des nazis
[Rires]
et vous pensiez donc nazis fort et
contrôle des cerveaux et vous pensiez
que qui sait que le gouvernement fait il
le fait pour vous non emballés lui ce
que l'homme
vous devriez changer d'idée la première
fois que le l'eau potable a été plus
aurait c'était dans les camps de
concentration de l'allemagne nazie la
gestapo devant consistant au pot les
bienfaits du tueur dans les enfants du
fluorure de sodium a été ajouté à l'eau
afin de les rendre humain stérile et
forcer les prisonniers du camp de
concentration adored dossier oui les
nazis y croyait des peco
de joseph bord qui est ce que joseph
biechlin et historien football il est
avocat auteur et un représentant du
gouvernement américain
monsieur joseph bord qui n'est pas
d'histoire donc je me garderai bien de
prendre tous sens comme argent comptant
la gestion régulière des quantités
infinitésimales de flore réduit la
capacité d'une personne à résister à la
domination en emploi devant et en
intoxiquant donc moins de 50 ans qui
nous servons cette personne devient donc
finir à l'avant auprès de ceux qui
désirent la gouverner ne bottoni légère
et pratique
huawei ouais m'enfin du coup si dans les
effets secondaires il y avait aussi
castration et tout pourquoi pourquoi
aujourd'hui on s'inquiète que du côté
lobotomie et pas du côté castration
parce que c'est quand même fichier c'est
quand même vachement plus facile à voir
aussi c'est à dire si le fluor qui avait
dans la flotte qu'on nous mène où rang
des lobotomisés et castrés ça se saurait
or je crois qu'il ya à peu près 10
milliards de personnes dans le monde
dans le pas deux milliards de personnes
on est 8 milliards à 10 milliards de
personnes et la population croit encore
et ça n'a pas l'air de marcher super
bien ces histoires de fluorés l'a
visiblement ça marche que pour la
lobotomie et pas pour la stérilisation
on croit on regarde la partie qui nous
intéresse l'espoir le n'est pas fluorés
pour améliorer la santé dentaire des
enfants si c'était la raison véritable
cela pourra se faire beaucoup plus
facilement à des coûts moindres et de
façon plus efficace la fluoration de
l'eau a comme but véritable de contrôler
et dominer la population plus facilement
et de et de lui faire accepter la perte
des libertés individuelles temps en
temps
et oui bah oui parce que de toute façon
quand on croit déjà de base que les
vaccins un canton quoi déjà de base que
les vaccins sont fait pour tuer l'élan
de toute façon on va dire qu'on peut
mettre du fluor dans l'eau les grandes
campagnes de vaccination nationale c'est
pareil c'était pas pour le bien des
landes c'était pour les tuer c'est écrit
à droite n'a hélas donc les grandes
campagnes nationales de fluoration de
l'eau c'est pareil c'est pour tuer les
gens quand les nazi d'hitler parce qu'il
ya des nazis 2.1 éclair ont envahi la
pologne les d'état-major allemand et
russe ont discuté de science et de
guerre et ils ont échangé des idées
tient on retrouve qui comprend des bals
des plans et du personnel le projet de
contrôler la masse par la compagnie
nationaux a particulièrement intéressé
les communistes russes qui y voyait une
façon idéale d'apposer une communisme au
monde entier tonton bon il ya des moyens
plus simple de contrôler les gens
veulent lire par des moyens par des
méthodes chimiques la drogue par exemple
le dire si vous avez basiquement une
population de gros vieux ou
d'alcooliques
voilà une population qui est vachement
plus aussi qui en plus et en plus il ya
une dépendance dont ce qui fait que si
vous contrôlez le petit robin est un de
cette substance où tout le monde est
dépendant
basiquement vous contrôlez la population
le jour la population se révolte puis
vous couper l'eau et basta les gens ils
ont tous un delirium tremens et puis là
ils se font tous un ils font tous une
crise de dépendance et puis et puis
voilà les gens ils deviennent lentilles
non vous vous rendez pas compte qu'il ya
des moyens beaucoup plus simple
d'arriver à contrôler les gens comme ça
et que si ça avait dû espèce aurait
plutôt être fait avec des moyens simples
qu'avec des moyens compliqué genre le
fluorure qui n'a pas d'effet sur le qui
n'a pas d'effets psychotropes connu en
plus et je dis je le rappelle ce rêve
serait responsable de castration voilà
on va castrés nos gens parce que leurs
impôts on n'en veut pas on veut pas d
impôt de l'argent des impôts des gens
jamais de la vie c'est parce que c'est
pas ça que les gouvernements font
bien sûr les gouvernements ne veulent
pas de nos impôts selon les chimistes
les mélange d'eau et de fluorure de
sodium sont le plus efficaces et les
moins coûteux pour tuer les rats oui
mais encore une fois c'est pas le même
type de fluorure de sodium on a montré
les deux formules chimiques sont
différentes
sans couleur sans odeur sans vous pas
d'antidote pas de remède pas d'espoir
les familles nation complète et
instantanée des rats et on voit comme ça
a marché pour nous on a bien été
exterminés lit dans la population a
quasiment doublé depuis les années 50
la fluoration de l'eau peut être un
suicide national en une liquidation
nationale rapide c'est de la folie
criminelle une trahison
ingénieur chimiste a le sens de m
monsieur bronner a numérisé il a avancé
il a inventé une marque de savon et il a
utilisé sa marque de savon pour
promouvoir ses idées morales et
religieuses
aie aie aie aie aie aie papier ji n'ont
pas de doctorat pour le dr bronner voilà
dr bronner est ingénieur à sans avoir de
doctorat j'aime bien l'argument j'aime
bien utiliser l'argument d'autorité
quand il y eut quand on le pointe
arbitrairement la prolonge pas moi aussi
j'ai bien retourné l'argument d'autorité
c'est ma petite chaussette plairait
l'argument d'autorité je retourne comme
aliment alimentation et glande pinéale
la propre idéal autrement connues comme
notre grande maîtresse nan c'est un
[ __ ] d'organes a confié régis notre
troisième oeil non pas qu'ils l'avaient
bien au début et elle le centre de la
conscience si chic dans un esprit humain
la conscience psychique dans l'esprit
manon moment la partie plus importante
de ce point de vue là ton cerveau ce
cortex préfrontal mais c'est pas grave
elle est de la taille d'un pois et se
situe dans une grotte située derrière la
glande pituitaire et produit
naturellement une hormone mélatonine qui
régule appelé les rythmes du corps qu
dia qui traitent directement avec les
jours et les cycles de la nuit kamoulox
traduction camunas développer et élargir
la fonction de l'énergie de votre grande
pinéale est extrêmement important car
elle affecte tous les systèmes de notre
corps physique et a le potentiel de
déterminer l'expansion de la contraction
de notre conscience ou psychique
kamoulox qu'est la lumière du soleil
extrêmement importante dans la glande
pinéale la lumière du soleil est
extrêmement importante pour la glande
pinéale et ça j'aimerais qu'on le
souligne
j'aimerais qu'on le souligne parce que
regarder où elle est votre [ __ ] de
glande pinéale l ema en plein milieu du
cerveau sous la sous la boîte crânienne
sous le corps pays
à la haye les enfermer dans une grotte
ils viennent de le lire
donc c'est important la lumière du
soleil pour la glande pinéale un bon bah
je vais vous montrer les tortues vermot
kelis pagnol voilà avec les portes une
mère elles ont aussi une glande pinéale
et comme beaucoup d'autres reptiles
comme je voulais montrer cette glande
pinéale années et les photos réceptive
et alors ce qu'il ya d'intéressant voilà
il ya plusieurs qui avaient repéré sens
c'est que quand on regarde dans le
cerveau quand on ouvre le cerveau de
tortue donc voilà c'est bon là c'est pas
le cerveau là le cerveau il est là c'est
plus petit le cerveau donc là on a la
boîte crânienne ils ont enlevé le
cerveau de la boîte crânienne et ils ont
mis un petit pointeur laser
là où se trouve la glande pinéale est
donc là où c'est intéressant c'est qu'on
voit que la lumière peut traverser la
boîte crânienne chez la tortue chez des
remous kelis la porte marine pourquoi
parce que regarder sur le sommet du
crâne de la torture et une petites
taches blanches petites taches blanches
qui est vite en fait que la peau absorbe
toute la lumière puisque le noir absorbe
complètement l'avènement donc là si ça
ça existait chez nous je serais d'accord
pour dire que la lumière du soleil avec
un effet mais [ __ ] par la cua la
glande pinéale elle est complètement
enterrée dans le cerveau chez les chez
les êtres humains pas pouvoir arrêter
bon là impossible à la lumière du soleil
c'est bullshit
quand un pompier le soleil est une forme
de nourriture pour les plantes oui la
lumière du soleil vous n'êtes pas un
organisme photosynthétiques bordel de
merde
la lumière du soleil peut être prises et
digérée par les yeux l'une il faut bien
sûr les cheveux les poils du nez et les
oreilles et doit être consommé pendant
au moins 30 minutes par jour
non non les cellules de notre peau
synthétise de la vitamine d grâce au
soleil c'est tout c'est tout arrêtez de
raconter de la merde il faut arrêter de
dire de la merde
temps mort les légumes ainsi que les
algues séchées au soleil contiennent des
quantités élevées de vitamines b et de
nombreuses vitamines du groupe b et de
diodes
certainement quel rapport avec la glande
pinéale les légumes à feuilles vert
foncé son testament nourrissant pour la
glande pinéale dans la mesure où elle
doit surtout avoir besoin de sucre au
pourquoi surtout le vert foncé le vert
foncé et pain est un très puissant
agents antioxydants
c'est important le vert foncé très
important la chimie du vert foncé c'est
de la balle la balle et c'est très
nourris si cette glande absorbe les
propriétés de la couleur verte des
légumes et les distribuer à des systèmes
appropriés de l'organisme afin que le
corps soit bien nourris ta mère elle
absente la glande pinéale absorbe les
propriétés de la couleur verte des
légumes
cette demande absorbe les chloroplastes
voilà des chloroplastes les petites
usines les petites usines qui change la
lumière du soleil en énergie à
l'intérieur des feuilles
c'est ça qui donne la couleur verte ce
groupe paye et vous êtes en train de me
dire que la glande pinéale assimile les
chloroplastes va te faire [ __ ]
sérieusement dans la whey j'ai réussi à
rester calmes et pas vulgaire mais l'a
sérieusement raconter de la merde comme
non les bons aliments peuvent influer
positivement sur votre demande pinéale
mais vous pouvez également activer votre
glande pinéale en mangeant plus
d'aliments crus ou en achetant une
machine un ozone pour votre maison qui
aidera la purification de l'air ambiant
les aliments crus ça se digère - dia que
les aliments cuits donc mon tu dois pas
forcément améliorateur tu vas pas
forcément améliorer la qualité de ton
alimentation en bouffon lui est une
machine à ozone mais tu as juste envie
de tuer tes gosses avec une machine à
ozone bordel de merde
les machines à ozone c'est ce que tu
sais ce que c'est utilisé les vétos pour
pas dans certains pays je ne sais pas si
c'est le cas en france mais les machines
à ozone puisque utilisent les métaux
pour euthanasier les animaux
petite chambre à ozone et pouf on tue
ton animal en douceur parce que c'est
s'asphyxie gentiment dorment ils
s'endorment quoi la machine avoue zone
dans la maison mais suicidaire là on
imagine que évidemment pour contrôler la
quantité aux autres je veux pas une
machine à monoxyde de carbone aussi non
parce que ça revient au même
la sérotonine autant que la glande
pinéale autant que la glande pinéale
besoin de lumière et la venue de là elle
doit également produire de la serre aux
deux de la sérotonine suffisante pour
être activé afin qu'elles puissent
augmenter sa conscience qui chérit or la
sérotonine est produite lorsque le
cerveau est endormi c'est pour ça qu'il
faut manger des gens ne le cerveau des
gens endormis est donc conseillé de
dormir dans une chambre très simple car
c'est extrêmement nourrissant pour la
finale
oui c'est mieux de dormir dans le noir
c'est plus facile mais encore une fois
je vois pas encore reprendre et moraux
coincé par rapport avec l'alimentation
manger des cerveaux de jean vandoorne de
longboard un déséquilibre de sérotonine
peut provoquer un état anxieux et un
goût excessif pour le sucré pour
synthétiser de la sérotonine nous avons
besoin d'un bassila d'un acide aminé de
l'alimentation de tri phones and le
profane parlons nos cellules nerveuses
le pense on dansait retenu puis il y en
a plus de neurones produit de la
sérotonine
mais pour des raisons d'ordre génétique
ou parce que l'alimentation d'un emploi
tout vent suffisant dans le très court
terme donc maintenant c'est vos neurones
qui produise de la sérotonine
c'est l'article qui te dit c'est la
glande pinéale qui fournit la sérotonine
et qui deux lignes plus loin de vie dans
ces neurones à sérotonine est
principalement produite par le système
nerveux autour du système garçons
cerveau c'est pas non plus le premier
producteur de sérotonine une ligue le
mans mais pour des raisons d'ordre
génétique ou parce que l'alimentation
n'apporte pas suffisamment le
tryptophane la synthèse de la sérotonine
peut être insuffisantes entraînant une
dépendance vis à vis du sucré que shrek
une personne sur trois ceci se
traduisant par l'audit a réhabilité de
la facilité de l'état des prix les
difficultés à trouver le sommeil et une
adhérence et ses sites pour le sucré ou
plus frais il personne sur 3 quel
rapport avec la finale
les aliments riches en tryptophane sont
souvent par souci allégresse les femmes
ont tendance à illescas répond
spontanément de la religion elles ont
aussi tendance à 2 à diminuer les
calories comme inverse cela n'est pas
une solution les aliments tout produit
naturellement de la sérotonine sur les
amendes les bananes le piment le riz les
pommes de terre le gouvernement aux
avocats mes haricots les lentilles et
certains fruits comme l'estomac comme
les tomates un aliment qui s'appelle
l'estomac dont les comateux les dates
les mois l'aide humaine aussi les acides
gras de la famille à trois qui facilite
l'action de la sérotonine bla bla bla
bla bla emploi sans rapport avec la
finale puisque la sérotonine n'est pas
principalement produite par le sait
qu'il faut éviter les boissons gazeuses
en général et l'eau du robinet en
consommer des produits animaux les
vagues y consommer des produits animaux
c'est pas bon quand on tape idéal voilà
c'est tout les poissons en conclusion
pour finir brièvement sur la glande
pinéale celle ci semblait preuve non
sans omettre notre lien avec l'univers
la matrice le champ comme le nommer
einstein ce champ qui fait de nous ce
que nous sommes deux points
[Rires]
nous sommes comme le dit ban ki moon
c'est pas vrai c'est donc la glande
pinéale comme il l'a tout à fait
démontré à travers cet article
on paie de elysian c'est la matrice
bah oui il y avait une image de matrix
dans la vidéo c'est le chant voilà le
champ le chant du cygne certainement
c'est d'ailleurs à travers une cette
glande pinéale que nous allons chercher
nos souvenirs nos lotos chorale
l'hypothalamus pinera vous pas plus que
la mémoire mais dans le lobe temporal
lobe temporal lpo thalamus la mémoire
principalement il n'y a pas que ça
évidemment le cerveau c'est plus
compliqué que ça pala pinel quoi nous
découvrons ainsi que notre mémoire n'est
pas situé dans notre cerveau dans ton
cul dans ton cul qui achètent à mémoire
si tu te soumets de tels son lycée quoi
merde mais que celui-ci l'écart est
cette perte alimentait la radio telle
perfection et il va chercher entre
autres nos souvenirs dans le champ et
oui sa mémoire elle n'est pas dans ta
tête c'est à pinéale qui sert à soutenir
et encore une fois les faits nos dont
ils ont une mémoire mon gars mais
d'enfer qui les êtres les plus
intelligents du monde du coup le spin o
gon avec leurs [ __ ] d'antenne 2 4 kg
mais de l'antenne avait presque aussi
grosses que le cerveau elle-même lui
même c'est vous dire s'il aurait
intelligent et plus long ce champ cette
map universelle qui ne vit tous les uns
les autres
les autres le web morpho génétique world
of warcraft
ah non pardon même et donc capables
d'interagir avec ce chant et de
nombreuses occasions télépathie
télékinésie ben oui c'est vrai j'ai tous
les week-ends
tous les week-ends la télékinésie pour
voir la théorie de greg brown braden
veut que nous ce que nous ne sommes pas
comme il était considéré jusqu'à présent
juste des observateurs des événements
qui sont lisses dans nos vies comme si
le destin elle avait décidé pour nous
avec à la perception que nous avons avec
notre vue le toucher le goût l'odorat et
notre ouïe
n'est que la perception du monde que
nous avons décidé d'ériger devant nous
nous deux nous devenons donc des
participes à peur quel rapport avec la
pinera vous êtes parti dans un délire
que je n'arrive plus à suivre là quel
est le rapport avec la pinéale le
système de contrôle du mental humain
ouais notamment le mien à mon mental là
il commence vraiment à brûler la peau
vraiment certains diront que cela a un
rapport avec les lois de l'attraction
pardon pour ce blanc vous a été offert
par l'oued de fuck production en fait
oui et non merci car la loi de
l'attraction est avant tout une non
alors la loi de l'attraction de tu fais
partie sur quel délire là les lois de
l'attraction qui décoiffe c'est einstein
ma pinéale einstein lois de l'attraction
à traction universelle et a vendu une
façon de nous amener à construire notre
propre mon physique et grâce à notre
comportement et nos pensées
mais d'un point de vue social la loi de
l'attraction est en effet redoutable car
si le croatie qui appliquent les champs
morpho génétique va jusqu'à la
matérialisation de notre environnement
dans notre seule volonté ils oublient
que nous sommes en fait tous téléguidé
sous l'effet des lignes de force ou
d'une de prédation qui nous relient les
inrocks en fonction des réseaux c'est
quoi ces lignes de force de prédation
qui minutes tu viens de dire qu'on était
des zep l'éliminer des participantes
heure est maintenant en fait on est plus
guidés par des lignes de force 6 pc
téléguidé par l'elysée porte est né hier
les résonances et leur mémoire
cellulaire cristallisé et attention en
rouge
pour lire la suite de cet article vous
devez être loguer en tant que membre
prévient cliquez ici pour passer en
premium
allez vous faire [ __ ] merci madame
quand je vous disais au début de
l'article qu'il avait un truc à vendre
un placement produit voilà générique de
fin merci laurent friman donc voilà si
vous voulez le harceler ses il est temps
de se réveiller points comme voilà il
est temps vous me il est temps de
patients premium.com mais non non et en
plus c'est un rite of daily chan paris
combien je veux voir l'article 2 et
nichane donc on est au système de
contrôle du mental humain copier
pourquoi et comment des tartes et votre
idéal par et nichane recherche
bon enfin la rue alors elle est pas
belle la vie
elle est pas belle l'avenir on n'essaye
pas peu de mouvements culé là vous la
sentez la sourde ou alors mémoire
cellulaire cristallisé bas on continue
du coup sûr et nichane donc voilà on a
fini sur les niches et ain nit par milla
le sahara on a commencé de déblocage des
pénitences a commencé avec elie chan et
le troisième épisode se termine sur et
nichane
la boucle est bouclée le grand cercle de
la vie c'est l'histoire de ce champ de
force devant fermement son taux est ce
que j'ai vraiment envie de finir de lire
ça banal à l'humilité la simplicité la
peur voilà donc c'est monsieur à va y
arriver
bail neuf qui a été canalisée par jean
luc et nous voilà le pauvre monsieur
ivanov s'est fait canalisée par jean-luc
à nouveau en même temps quand on
s'appelle jean luc on est plutôt bon
pour qualifier les gens n'osent pas dans
ce cas là du coup sifflet jean luc et
voilà exactement le système de contrôle
du mental humain est entretenu par
l'ensemble des croyances par le karma
par l'adn mais aussi par notre
comportement va durer peut-être
commencer par le comportement et nous
sommes toujours complètement conscient
de ce comportement pour l'interrogation
excusez moi du coup ça fait et nous
sommes toujours
vêtements conscient de son contentement
nos pensées ne sont pas les nôtres
bah oui elles nous ont été elles nous
sont commandés par des reptiliens toi
tard à voir des reptiliens ce fait nos
dons avec leur glande pinéale ils nous
envoient des signaux dans nos têtes
ces [ __ ] [ __ ] de ce fait nous
devrons le détartrage de la glande
pinéale c'est pour mieux recevoir le
signal baissier dodon et du cou et du
coup ça nous rend plus esclave des
reptiliens
et ça pousse ça s'arrête faut que ça
s'arrête ah non pardon c'est le
contraire le détartrage de la glande
pinéale semble être la solution la plus
simple pour sortir du pilotage
automatique auxquelles nous sommes
soumis par nos choix d'incarnation
conclusion allez vous faire opérer à
cerveau ouvert voilà on défonce
lapidaire et c'est bon et ils le savent
sinon est il avec les belles mères un
complot évidemment sinon on n'aurait pas
de fluor dans l'eau du robinet on a plus
de fluor dans l'eau des robinets
en septembre 2005 le ministère de la
santé et des services sociaux du québec
demandé à toutes les villes de la
province de fluorés d'eau potable soit
disant pourquoi venir les caries
dentaires chez les enfants défavorisés
voilà c'est de là qu'il ya un parti
c'est un article le canadien
certainement et la france n'est pas d'en
être bien long bien au contraire de
fluor dans l'eau depuis les années 80
mode d'élimination du fluor selon le
petit monde de cosi lui non ben oui
parce que quitte à kita plier
monumentalement le contenu d'autres
sites et doté rick ballon est lassé
l'inception des eaux terrible on a
commencé sur stop mensonges ont fini sur
le petit monde de casino donc moins
inversé la filtration par l'osmose est
utilisé pour purifier plusieurs ligues
d'eau embouteillée de sorte que
certaines zones de bouteilles sont non
chlorée système à osmose inverse sont
également donc là on est en plus c'est
encore une traduction violente et
dégueulasse mode et fluoration à lui
inactivé filtre ces chiffres sont
utilisés dont je vais arrêter là
j'arrête là si c'est même plus le
français distillation de filtration il
existe dans le commerce des filtres
disponibles par distillation qui peuvent
être achetés dans une chiffre lors les
filtres brita ça marche pas parce que
c'est les illuminati l'ébullition de
l'eau ça marche pas parce que ça
entre ce qu'il ya dedans beaucoup la
congélation de l'eau ça marche pas parce
que pourquoi ça marche le rêve mesurer
pour réduire l'exposition au fluor ne
prenait pas de supplément au fluor et
tout ça pour éviter éviter l'utilisation
à long terme donné évidemment que quand
on vous fluor
elle est votre médecin vous empoisonner
on la revoit alors voilà ou photos de
sérotonine parce que parce que la glande
pinéale la clé de l'élimination le
chercheur en psychologie shirts i qui
les lie rick strootman a expliqué
comment la glande pinéale est plutôt
actif pour synthétiser les composés
relative à sérotonine important dans mon
compte notre cerveau les
neurotransmetteurs son messager chimique
permettant la communication pour ces
dernies individuel tu sens la citation
la citation d'un véritable docteur qui a
été niée hors de contexte parce que ce
qu'ils disent est vrai à la limite par
que la plupart des drogues
psychédéliques typiques tels que le lsd
la mescaline la psychobilly d'abc no 6
rebonds et le dr vite et sont actives
dans les régions du cerveau également
accompli par la sérotonine de plus la
plupart des drogues sont similaires dans
leur structure chimique
oui c'est bien pensé qu'elle m'en allais
faire et si on parlait du cannabis voilà
c'est jacques morel nouvelle étude des
textes bibliques si on parlait du
cannabis pour l'interrogation une
nouvelle étude des textes bibliques des
révèle que le canal bowser du cannabis
était utilisé par dans des huiles donc
son élan sans que jésus qu'il n'est au
cours des cérémonies habituelles de
guérison là on sort de mon champ de
compétence voilà de toute façon je suis
plus sur l'article de stock mans sont
donc moi je considère que j'ai fait mon
boulot
allez vous faire [ __ ] allez vous faire
[ __ ] avec votre cannabis thérapeutique
contre la calcification de la glande
pinéale vous n'avez même pas démontré
que c'était un vrai problème
alors merde
merde ok merde bon voila moi moi je
pense que j'ai fait j'ai fait le j'ai
fait le taf avait fait le taf je suis
arrivé jusqu'au bout de la page
stop mensonge j'ai tiré un peu de
prolongation sur initial mais ça suffit
j'ai déjà fait et l'initiale donc non
j'arrête
l'art est c'est tout voilà le cannabis a
essayé le cannabis ça va vous détartrer
et voilà allez-vous faire des tas refait
tous autant que vous êtes allez vous
faire canalisée par l'onudc
faites-vous détartrer au cannabis et
vous faire canalisée par jour lui parce
que moi j'en ai marre
donc voila merci laurent friman pour ce
grand moment sur la glande pinéale du
troisième oeil de nous avoir montré donc
que tu n'y connaissais rien que tu n'as
pas fait les micros au micro secondes de
recherches que j'ai fait
tu ne les as pas fait que tu as raté
tous les arguments valables qui allait
dans son sens que tu as un rip off et
copier coller le site daily chaîne sans
autre forme de procès qui était bien
plus sérieux que le tiens d'ailleurs
bien mieux écrit encore que traduction
kaka une peau plus de nous avoir
et merci de nous avoir vendre nous avoir
donné raison en nous mettant qu'il
fallait une connexion premium pour lire
la fin d'un article qui n'est même pas
le tiens voilà donc ce fut un grand
moment
merci à tous d'avoir suivi ce débat en
cage et pénitence numéro 3 et comme
comme apparemment tous les youtube
heures se sont donné le mot pour qu'on
finisse par par des phrases de 4,13 et
bien j'ai inventé ma propre catch price
désormais je finirai tous mes épisodes
par si dieu avait voulu qu'on soit
créationnistes il n'aurait pas inventé
les fossiles ça n'a rien à voir et je
m'en bats les couilles
voilà merci à tous et à la prochaine
fois